if you only saw them on their big day
every February you might think that
groundhogs are pretty shy animals
they're actually anything but what
started out as a funny sight turned a
little bit scary for a man from Hampton
you see those teeth on that guy
imagine finding this at your front door
they might be called groundhogs but
they're not related to hogs at all
they're actually the largest species in
the squirrel family and they are equally
ubiquitous you can find groundhogs all
over the central in eastern us in
Arkansas for example there's an
estimated 67 thousand that's about one
groundhog for every 45 humans and
wherever they are they make their
presence known
similar to beavers groundhogs have
rapidly growing incisors which they keep
from growing too long by chewing and
gnawing on just about anything they can
get their teeth on including cables
hoses and other rubbery materials one
groundhog reportedly chewed the wires
inside of a car in Nebraska costing
eighteen hundred dollars in damage
repairs but they don't just wreak havoc
above-ground
groundhogs are burrowers by Nature they
live breed and hibernate underground but
before they can do that they have to dig
and dig and dig and dig and dig and dig
their tunnels can be anywhere from half
a meter deep to one and a half meters
deep and they could be up to 18 meters
long that's about as long as a bowling
lane their burrows can harm crops
weakened foundations of buildings and
damaged farm equipment that may fall in
in one case it's been said they dug up
bones in the cemetery
but even if you don't have a lot of land
your home could still be a target
groundhogs like grassy open areas
because they don't have big obstacles
like tree roots and giant rocks so that
pretty little garden or that freshly
mowed lawn that is a free-for-all for
groundhogs and a fence won't keep them
out either because they could just Earl
underneath it or climb over yeah that's
right groundhogs can climb too for
example during floods they've been known
to climb chain-link fences to escape
rising water and just about the only way
to keep them out is an electric fence
which can cost between a hundred and
three hundred and fifty dollars
depending on the size of your yard and
removing a groundhog from your property
getting a wildlife control professional
to help could cost about $400 per
groundhog worst comes to worst you
definitely don't want to try and handle
them on your own since some groundhogs
can be pretty aggressive animals for
example in 2018 the groundhog chased a
woman in the parking lot of her office
building luckily she made it to her car
but even then when her co-workers came
to help her the groundhog forced them to
retreat back inside even worse
groundhogs have been known to carry
rabies which can make them even more
aggressive and dangerous so maybe don't
keep them near your face